90 plus percent of winning in anything
you try to do in America today you got
to be excited see if you want to win
folks you got it you got to stand up and
you got to say I'm so sick and tired of
being average and ordinary I never
forgave them for what they did to my
mama and what they did to me and Angela
and I was out to punish him the first
few plays are critical you got a hit
hard and show him who's boss if you
understand this one sentence you're
guaranteed to be wealthy he's the
founder of Al Williams & Associates
known as Primerica since 1991 he built
al Williams & Associates to be the
largest seller of life insurance in the
United States in 2008 Forbes estimated
his net worth to be 1.4 billion dollars
he's art Williams and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number four is my personal favorite I
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips
also as artists talking if he says
something that really resonates with you
make sure to leave in the comments below
and put quotes around it so others can
be inspired as well 90 plus percent of
winning in anything you try to do in
America today you got to be excited
people America won't follow or believe
in a negative dull disillusioned
frustrated dadgum crybaby people all
people that are positive and excited and
enthusiastic and tough the greatest
lesson the greatest definition I ever
heard I thought about this ten million
times when I wanted to quit along the
way of a winner this guy said almost
everybody in America can stay excited
for two or three months a few people can
stay excited for two or three years but
a winter a stay excited for 30 years
ever how long it takes to win see if you
want to win folks you got it you got a
and up and you got to say I'm so sick
and tired to be an average an ordinary
I'm so sick and tired of telling myself
and telling my wife and telling my mama
in telling everybody I'm going when I
found at this time watch my slow see
folks if you go win you gonna change the
only way you can change life the only
way the future can be better than the
past is you gotta change nobody can
change far you okay nobody's going to
give you something for nothing it's
going to be up to you you're controlling
your future and if you don't change just
look in the dadgum mirror look at the
last five to ten years of your life in
the next five or ten years going to be
just like that ain't that depressing
this theme that I adopted nobody wants a
boss but everybody wants a coach you
know if you're going to be a great
leader and you're going to lead your
people to great success you've got to
have a coaches heart and a coach is
trained to look for the good things in
people you know everybody every piece of
flesh has ever been going born at one
time in their life for dreamers they
felt good about themselves but do you
realize that ninety percent of the
people that you recruit in business
today on the outside they might look
confident you know but inside folks
they've been crushed
you know they've lost their confidence
people have treated them bad they've
almost given up on themselves and it's
your ability as a coach to look inside
those people and see something good and
help them to believe in themselves again
to feel good about themselves again just
going to determine you know how far you
take your team I believe desire and will
to win is everything I don't know why
I'm like I am but my butt's always
burning there's always something say art
dadgummit you're supposed to go for it
art dadgummit you're supposed to be
somebody you're supposed to make a
difference with you
I what does the $500,000 your person do
the $50,000 your person doesn't do you
look at outside and study those two
individuals everything seems to be the
same they both are the same sex they
both are the same age have the same
training the same positions the same
contract the same fringe benefits
they both are successful they work hard
they're good family people make tough
commitments but what's the difference
what does the $500,000 your person do
the $50,000 your person doesn't do he
pays the price and a little bit more he
works Harding a little bit more he's
loyal to the company a little bit more
he believes a little bit more he makes
mine a little bit more he saves money a
little bit more if you want to win in
these United States you got to be tough
and you can't quit the last thing I'll
talk to you about today and building
this winning edge is folks if you want
to win in business you've got to be a
leader leadership is everything you show
me anything in these United States that
win I'll show you a leader at work you
show me a successful church Boy Scout
Troop club football team business I'll
show you some a run by leader see see I
thought at one time in my life you had
to be smart to win I used to have these
smart people that dress so pretty and
talk so pretty and use these big words
they just intimidated me I said aren't
you can't ever be that good why don't
you just throw in the towel and go on
back coach football for living and I
found two things out about smart people
I think it's almost impossible for a
smart person to win in business in
America today because I find smart
people spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out they always trying
to figure out an easier way in a quicker
way and another thing I found out about
smart people's they just don't get
around to doing nothing they see
somebody like art Williams everybody
said well he can't do it and so
like that can't do it but he does it see
folks I want you to know almost
everybody in America almost does enough
to win they almost get there they almost
over the hump
they almost have it going they almost in
everything they do almost is a way of
life to almost everybody in America but
the winners do it what do they do they
do whatever it takes to get the job done
they do it and do it and do it and do it
and do it until the job gets done and
then they talk about how great it is to
be somebody they're proud of we need
leaders in America who can do it if you
want to become somebody do it if you
want to go in business for yourself do
it if you want to become financially
independent do it I hear too much talk
in these United States everybody can
talk a good game we need people in
America who can do it I go all over this
country with Al weaves and I have people
say aren't you you count on me
wonderful just do it all right I
guarantee this is my light last stop I'm
gonna win now SuperDuper just do it all
right if I could just have one good
month and get the ball going I know I
could make it big super just do it hard
if I could just pay off this debt I
could really go great just do it
hard if I could just sell my house do it
but house they selling do it anyway
I'm not making any money what can I do
you just do it and do what art you do it
and do it and do it alright I get to
have a win this contest
SuperDuper just do it alright I'm over
the hump now watch my smoke grades just
do it
alright I want to make it so bad I'm
tasting what I do you just do it hard
I'm a vice president now can I quit
doing it no my heart I don't know if I
keep on keeping on I'm really hurting
what I do you just do it do what art you
do it and do it and do it art all my
life I want to be somebody important
well what do it then alright I'm gonna
save money so I don't have to go through
this again gray hey just do it alright I
don't feel like I've had enough training
what I do you just do it alright my
manager don't give me no help what I do
you just do it harsh you don't
understand I was mr. everything in my
former company you don't mean I I have
to start off down at the bottom and do
it do you yep you really got to do it ah
art was the primary difference between
winners and losers the winner the
winners do it they do it and do it and
do it and do it until the job gets done
and then they talk about how great it is
to finally have achieved something
unique and how glad they are that they
didn't quit like everybody else and how
wonderful it is to finally be somebody
they're proud of and make a difference
with their life the key to winning is
not Thailand it's not looks it's not
degrees I believe the key to winning is
being the best you can possibly be
I believe if you're proud of your
abilities and your opportunity if you
look in the mirror and you say that
guy's supposed to win you know he's
supposed to be somebody you know and you
go out there and you go fight and you be
the best you can be
you're gonna have a lot of defeats along
the way if you're going to be in so many
situations that looks so hopeless but if
you just keep me in the best you can be
it's going to look impossible a time
just keep being the best you can be all
you can do is all you can do but all you
can do is enough when we found out that
you know cash pay life insurance was a
ripoff of my term investor difference
was a way to go and they had screwed our
family I'm telling you what I never
forgave them for what they did to my
mama and what they did to me and Angela
and I was out to punish them I wanted to
hurt him and that's the way they a
Williams people were and the more they
tried to you know destroy us was just
millions of wars that we went through
you know you know when you're a crusader
Crusaders die hard and so we just made
us more determined to show them you know
we were gonna let those the enemy you
know defeat us you know another key to
building this winning edge in this
mental toughness is you got to become a
dreamer again you know I'm a Methodist
we just changed ministers a few weeks
ago and our new minister came in and and
the church was just packed and the first
thing he said he says well looks like
everybody came out to see the monkey
perform and the second and second thing
out of his mouth he said for church to
be a great Church you got to have a
dream if you don't have a dream you're
dead
and boy I sat up and I said man me and
this guy gonna get along good because he
knows what he's talking about
see folks I believe in order to win you
got to feel good about yourself I I was
coaching football for seven years back
in Georgia and I had a paddle in my
coaching office there's about this thick
and this long and in the fat end I had
little holes bought in it so you could
really get some speed and bliss to the
little but you know when they misbehaved
and and I had a rule on my football team
that if any kid said I can't if any
football player hurt I heard one of my
football players said I can he got to
bring him in the coach's office and give
him three legs and it took me about a
month to get all that thinking out of my
players every year you know and I'd have
football players knock on my door at
recess and at lunch and after school and
he said coach he said it coach he said
it and I'd make that kid bend over and
I'd give that other kid the board hit
busting three times and folks it didn't
take long you couldn't create a word
to get one of my semi kids to say I
can't bring it home a little bit more
personal in April a little art where
we're just this little and could
understand words every time they said I
can made them do three push-ups folks
there ain't nothing you can't do in
America if you want too bad now lay your
wings didn't debt by term events the
difference but we were the first group
of people that took that crusade to the
American consumer out there you know and
yes that's why we're number one I
believe the first step to winning in
business is you've got to do what's
right for the consumer out there I
believe your reputations everything if
you don't do what's right 100 percent of
time you might get by for one day one
week one month one year but certainly
they gonna bail you out
we're folks by term invest the
difference is right and we've stood the
heat like you couldn't believe and
that's why we're number one I tell our
kids I said hi fellas you know football
is not a team game it is in an and C
football is really a game against you
and that guy in the wrong Kyle Cole
jersey lining up across from you
somebody's going win you or him and the
person is wins is gonna want it the most
this bit us there's nothing but an
attitude business so you got to prepare
to win the first few plays are critical
you gotta hit him hard and show him
who's boss sissie somebody's going to
quit you or him and you got to look for
every weakness see when he starts
sweating hard you know you got him on
the run hit him hard knock him out with
chalky mud if he starts breathing hard
you know he's sucking eggs hit him hard
knock him out and we chalk him up if he
starts bleeding you know you buy guy hit
him hard knock him out and we talked him
up I said don't you ever show weakness
out there I'll never let one of my teams
get down on the knee I said it timeout
you turn and look into me and I you
watch him on his knee when he takes his
head off you see how much he's sweating
you want you to see how much water you
drink you know you got him hurting him
and knock him out and we chalk him up
I'm gonna give you mine
our management philosophy folks that I
developed over 19 years in one sentence
I'm all bald everything down in one
sentence if you understand this one
sentence you're guaranteed to be wealthy
I was in Philadelphia 3 weeks ago during
this super seminar with 10000 termites
just likes in this arena here yeah you
know Philadelphia this is the 200 year
celebration of signing our constitution
everybody's blood interface a fun place
to go right now you know on every corner
in Philadelphia you know they got
statues of George Washington and
Benjamin Franklin and Thomas Jefferson
and they got all these famous sayings of
all these great American heroes but you
know what there's probably never been a
human being on the face of this earth
this ever said anything as smart as I'm
fixing to tell you
hey let's hey hey let's listen listen
folks this is the answer the total
answer to being successful in business
this is the management philosophy that
will make you a superstar
in business can you believe that an old
football coach with a PE degree and an
average IQ could think of something so
brilliant now now listen I think about
this folks think about this how many
pieces of flesh have lived on this earth
nobody knows right but do you know do
you know as much as I can determine
I am the single human being this lived
on this earth that said this first
hey let's listen hey listen listen
there's probably never been a more
brilliant statement uttered from the
lips of a human man than what I'm fixed
to tell you hey listen listen listen
listen listen probably one day you're
going to see a monument to art Williams
it is going to have a disco had this
dadgum statement on it hey food do you
understand what I'm telling you I'm
telling you a management philosophy in
one sentence that guarantees you to be a
superstar in business hey listen listen
do you know Benjamin Franklin I never
said nothing compared to what I'm fixed
to tell you today's Chicago
I
hi listen listen you don't miss it
this is pure genius folks this is all
there is wrapped up in one sentence nine
words guaranteed to make you wealthy you
ready go save you thousands and foul
of hours of agony in frustration
are you ready alright here it is here it
is my entire management philosophy
listen the whole ballgame guaranteed to
make you a superstar here it is all you
can do is all you can do
is that free admission is that Raya
okay listen
okay listen listen listen
now listen
I listen I listen listen
Alisa
this is
I listen
ah
I listen
listen
I listen our folks I'm fixing to give it
to you now listen most important thing
you'll ever hear in Venice in America
today now all you can do is all you can
do they nothing more than all you can do
that is the absolute maximum you can't
do no more than all you can do you
understand that all you can do is all
you can do all you can do is everything
that's the absolute ultimate right but
the second part of that saying
is all you can do is all you can do but
all you can do is a nun
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because JaJuan Peele
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are made of
profile next leave it down the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I also
love to know which of our top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why
how is it going to change your life or
your business leave in the comments and
I will join in the discussion thank you
so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon
the system must be simple you know when
I was coaching football I thought I was
I was a quarterback in high school a
quarterback in college and I was this
assistant coach for two years down in
Thomasville Georgia when I got my first
head coaching job I had a playbook
there was about you know this thick man
I had everything figured out I was an
offensive whiz you know and when I went
to my first coaching job I had this you
know complicated playbook you know and
and all that kind of stuff my I was a
head coach for five years in Georgia in
my last year when we won the
championship my playbook was seven pages
thick the system's got to be simple you
know it's got to be simple you know I
used this example about the Prudential
rate book when we kicked their butt 1984
look at that red book it was one inch
thick they had dozens and doesn't kind
of products this is a always Williams
rate book one page we had one product we
had one product we sold the consumer
term insurance
we sold term insurance a hundred percent
of the dadgum time we sold everybody the
same dadgum product we owned on our own
dadgum life ain't that - what kind of
ain't that the way ain't that the kind
of kunti you want to be part of you know
you might not like us you might not come
to work with us you might not buy our
dadgum product but you never have to
back in the door when you when you
belong to a Oh Williams we do what's
right for the consumer every time we say
you what we own in our own life every
time it's got to be simple and the
bigger you get the more complicated your
job gets you've got to have the ability
to keep it simple and to spend you know
I use this little formula 90% of your
time on the important things and the
important things in our business are
always the people things and that's what
you do when you're starting out you're
dealing with the people you're
recruiting people you're motivating
people you're building friends with your
people and then all of a sudden you get
into compliance and you get into
administration and your job becomes more
meetings and planning and all this kind
of crap you know and and before you know
what you're spending ten percent of your
time on the important stuff people and
ninety percent of your time
on administrative paperwork all this
kind of crap that doesn't make any money
you've got to constantly strive to keep
your business simple and to focus and
spend your time on the important things
another key in building this winning
edge is folks you got to stand for
something people in America the good
people in America fed up with here with
these dadgum fence sitters and mealy
miles corporate America has an
especially black eye in business today
most people America think you can't find
a company they think you can't find a
salesperson that will tell you like it
is and stand behind the word they think
these companies will sell anything say
anything just to make a sale just to
make a profit well you know what folks
if you want to win in the free
enterprise system in America today you
got to stand for something folks the
difference in the great coaches and the
average and ordinary coaches is the
ability to get momentum and to keep
momentum think about this folks al
Williams for 20 consecutive years grew
now during those 20 consecutive years we
changed companies five times I had to
terminate the number one producer in our
company on two different occasions and
it was almost impossible to get
terminated you know from ayo williams we
had wars with the regulators we were
kicked out of Mississippi for two weeks
Canada pass through where there was no
part-time recruits Texas limited the
number of recruits we could 350 a year
and with all of that al Williams grew
for 20 straight years now how do you
grow this is the difference in a pro a
real pro and an average and ordinary
coach there are three things you do now
to guarantee you keep momentum when you
get it going number one you grow by
multiplication you grow by
multiplication
you've got to always be promoting people
the district leader to division leader
to our VP okay because once you get
things growing by multiplication then
what you have or you have hundreds then
hundreds or thousands of people that are
doing what you are trying to do okay
building friends praise and recognizing
people recruiting best friends does that
make sense and see once you have once
your growing my multiplication that's
the greatest opportunity for you to keep
that momentum that you've kept okay that
makes sense all right number two the
second thing and keeping this momentum
once you have it is you've got to have
an enemy you've got to have some kind of
injustice out there you're trying to
create you know you've got to have an
edge I don't care if you in the in the
real estate business right if somebody's
charging a charging a let's say a ten
percent commission on just raw land that
you sell out there then you do it fate
and a half percent or something right
you've got to have an edge over the
enemy you've got to have an enemy you're
trying to beat out there right now we
were fortunate to have the worst enemy
in the whole history of the world right
the trash value guys right but but
you're selling a crusade there's nothing
that energizes people and keep that
momentum going like a like a crusade
right you're out there trying to save
the world you're trying to make a
difference with your life right and then
the third thing is you have competition
competition inside the company I was a
master at promoting competition inside
the company right like a Laurence Walker
I get him taking on a dick Walker you
know down in Tampa Florida you know I'm
I was I had oh I had a gift of always
egging people alone along a little bit
okay
so if you want to if you want to keep
momentum once you get it there are three
keys you grow by multiplication you keep
recruiting this folks for 20 years
it's preseve a Williams the first thing
I look for every day on my desk
Cathy hearing my secretary the first
thing I did when I went in the office
before I talked to boo or anybody and
gotten and got in my million things I
needed to do okay the first thing I did
every morning was look at recruiting
numbers first thing I did every morning
the second thing I did was sign 200 gogo
letters that's the first thing I did and
got that out of the way first thing
every morning right and so you've got to
have a women talk to you about that in
the morning to monitoring this kind of
stuff so when you know you can tissa
pate when you are slowing down right
when you're you're fixing hit a brick
wall down the road correct
so if you if you're growing by
multiplication if you've got people out
there recruiting best friends you're
picking up policies of best friends you
know making presentations to best
friends building friends were there
recruits praising recognizing people
promoting district managers promoting
division manager promoting our VPS and
you've got people you're teaching people
how to do all these same kind of things
to build these powerful relationships
right then you're guaranteed that you're
going to keep that momentum going if you
have an enemy you've got to have an
enemy you've got to have something you
get people riled up about and then the
third thing is you create competition
inside your own organization or inside
the company right